the leak reveals that house of the
dragon will feature one of the most
legendary brother vs brother duel in
westeros history bentwin brothers who
deeply loved each other also fought each
other because one of them sided with
aegon and the other with rhaenyra a
leaked audition tape was recently posted
and shortly after deleted featuring two
tween actors reading the parts of
legendary cargile brothers
r.a kinerick
in this leaked audition tape actors who
are identical to in-street a scene in
which their characters are kinerick
discuss the rights of prince aegon soon
to become king aegon their dialogue and
physical gestures suggest that they are
guarding the prince while he visits a
brothel
something for which aegon was very known
eric is disturbed by prince aegon's
behavior and wonders aloud what sort of
king for westeros aegon will be if this
is how he acts as a prince well arik
insists that all men are equally bad and
they should accept him for what he is
oryx says that the hand of the king
seroto hightower who is also aegon's
grandfather will keep him in check but
eric still doesn't like the idea of fake
on ruling westeros
anyways that's the leaked audition tape
that spoiled a huge plot in house of the
dragon
so who are these rake and eric brothers
they are twin brothers and both are
members of the kingsguard under king
viserys
but they fought on opposite sides of the
dance of the dragons and ended their
lives with a legendary duel which
inspired many songs in westeros
in this league eric doubts that prince
aegon will make a good king
foreshadowing his allegiance to rhaenyra
over aegon while arik is determined to
stand by the prince regardless of his
faults because he thinks he is the
rightful heir
sir arik and sir eric cargile are
knights from house cargile they are
members of the kingsguard during the
reign of king viserys the first
targaryen
but when the king dies then his son and
daughter each declare themselves the
rightful rulers of westeros the cargill
brothers are divided for the first time
arik ends up siding with aegon targaryen
and eric with rhinera targaryen
according to septemeustas
auric found prince daemon and princess
rhaenyra targaryen in bed together a few
months after the tourney to celebrate
king viserysus and queen alison's fifth
anniversary in 111 ac
which is why he thinks princess rhaenyra
is not much better than aegon meanwhile
in 120 ac king viserys the first
targaryen made eric the sworn shield of
princess rhaenyra targaryen replacing
sir harvin strong
after the death of viserys eric followed
sir stephen darkling and sir laurent
marbrand in siding with the blacks
and joined the queensguard of rhaenyra
his brother arik however supported
rhaenyra's rival king aegon ii targaryen
and the greens
after the coronation of aegon in the
dragonpit auric led the king into the
throne room of the red keep rhaenyra's
coronation occurred shortly after on
dragonstone as prince damon placed an
old king's crown on the head of his wife
proclaiming her rhaenyra of house
targaryen first of her name queen of the
andals the rhoynar and the first men
when word of rhaenyra's coronation
reached the red cape the next day aegon
was furious
cooler heads on the green council wished
to
so grand maester orwell was dispatched
across blackwater bay under a piece
banner leading a retinue that included
sir arik cargile of the kingsguard in
something that ended up being an
unsuccessful attempt to reconcile the
rival targaryens the terms offered by
the king were generous
if queen rhaenyra would acknowledge him
as king
aegon would confirm her in possession of
dragonstone and allow the island and
castle to pass to her son upon her death
pardons would be granted to all lords
and knights including eric who had
conspired against him rhaenyra heard
these terms in silence eric by her side
as well as most of the blacks
then asked grandmas rorwell who
presented her these terms on aegon's
behalf if he remembers her father king
viserys who named her as his heir and
successor not aegon
grand maester replied that he remembers
that the king named her his heir
rhaenyra nodded and said with your own
tongue you admit i am your lawful queen
why then do you serve my half-brother
aegon the pretender orwell gave a long
reply citing the end of law and the
great council of 101. the answer did not
satisfy rain era a grand maester should
know the law and servant she told him
you are not grand maester and you only
bring shame and dishonor to that chain
you wear
zoro while protested cerarix stripped
his chain of office from his neck and
forced him to his knees while the
princess bestowed the chain upon her own
maester as she sent orwill and ceraric
back to king's landing rhaenyra said
tell my half-brother that i will have my
throne or i will have his head
many years after the targaryen civil war
was done a singer loose son of tarth
would compose a sad ballad called
farewell my brother that is still sung
to this day the song tells the story of
the last meeting between steroic and his
twinster eric cargile as orwell's party
was boarding the ship that would carry
them back to king's landing
soraric had sworn his sword to aegon sir
eric to rhaenyra
in that song each brother tries to
persuade the other to change signs
upon realization that each failed they
exchange declarations of love and go
their separate ways knowing that when
they meet again they will meet as
enemies
upon a few following events orrick will
go on a mission to dragonstone where he
will meet and fight his brother eric to
death
it all started when rhaenyra's second
son lucerus flew on his dragon to
storm's end to gain an alliance with
house baratheon but taegon ii's brother
aymond flew to storm's end at the same
time to pursue the same goal
riding the older dragon vegar
storm zen subsequently supported dagon
ii
amend riding vagar killed luke over
shipbreaker bay as he attempted to leave
after failing to gain lord baratheon's
allegiance
this then led to rhaenyra and daemon
taking revenge against aegon and sending
blood and cheese nicknames of two men
who sneaked into the red keep and killed
his son a son for a son
this then led to king aegon's desire to
avenge the killing of isaiah by blood
and cheese by means of an attack on
dragonstone descending on the island
citadel and dragonback to seize or slay
rhaenyra and her sons
it took all of the green council to
change his strategy sir kristen cole
urged a different course rhaenyra had
made use of stealth and tracheary to
kill his son cole said to aegon so let's
do the same he continued we will pay the
princess back in our own bloody coin he
told the king the instrument the lord
commander of the kingsguard chose for
the king's vengeance was his sworn
brother sir arik cargile
many fishermen arrived daily on
dragonstone so it would be a simple
thing to deliver auric to the island
from there he would make his own way to
the queen pretending to be sir eric for
auric and eric were twins identical in
all respects not even their fellow
members of the kingsguard could tell the
two apart
ceraric should be able to move freely at
dragonstone sir kristen suggested as any
guards to encounter him would surely
mistake him for his brother
after king aegon gave this mission a
green light lord commander of aegon's
kingsguard and therefore our explored
commander as well sir kristen ordered
daryk to infiltrate dragonstone although
it's disputed whether his mission was to
kill rhaenyra or her children or even
both
sororic did not undertake his mission
happily he thought this to be
dishonorable for a knight of the king's
guard
septemus says that arik visited the red
keep set on the night he was to sail for
dragonstone to pray for forgiveness to
mother above
yet as king's guard sworn to obey king
and commander he had no choice in honor
but to do as commanded or die trying
ceraric came a short dragonstone donned
his armor and white cloak and had no
trouble gaining entrance to the castle
in disguise of his twin brother deep in
the hearth of dragonstone as he was
making his way to the royal apartments
where rhaenyra and her sons were the
gods brought arik face to face with his
brother sir eric who knew at once what
his brother's presence meant
sararick said i love you brother as he
drew his blade and sarorik replied i
love you too brother as he drew his own
the twins battled for the best part of
an hour the clash of steel and steel
woke half of the queen rhaenyra scored
but all they could do was stand by
helplessly and watch for no man could
tell which brother was which in the end
sir arik and zerarik dealt each other
immortal wounds and died in one
another's arms with tears upon their
cheeks that's the story of the legendary
cargile brothers
when i say targaryen fought targaryen
dragon fought the dragon and brother
fought brother during the targaryen
civil war i mean it and you will see it
for yourself in 2022 on hbo thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
video please give it a big thumbs up and
i hope to see you in the next one peace